jena vor wenigen tagen das betreten
aller öffentlichen orte ist offiziell
verboten
rausgehen nur fürs nötigste noch erlaubt
michael kroner lebt mit behinderungen
doch auf der bank auf der er sich
ausruhen will ist jedes verweilen unter
sagt ich wollte mich in dem moment
alleine dorthin setzen ja umso waren
wird nächstes jahr auch noch für mich ja
also ich meine wenn abschnitte
eingehalten werden wieso soll man sich
nicht auf banker setzen können ich meine
ein meter fünfzig jahren zwei meter okay
jetzt sind okay aber verweigert wurde
meine die leute denken einfach nicht
mehr darüber nach was sie tun ist meine
meinung
in der korona krise hat die regierung
die grundrechte massiv eingeschränkt
dafür dass einige verbote jetzt
gelockert werden will
gesundheitsminister sparen an anderer
stelle verschärfen er will kontrolle
über unsere handy daten sind wir für
einen begrenzten zeitraum um den geht es
ja nicht für immer sondern um diesen
begrenzten zeitraum bereit bestimmte
zugriffe auf handy daten möglich zu
machen wenn wir dafür im gegenzug
bestimmte auch ja jetzt freiheits
eingreifende maßnahmen dann entsprechend
auch wieder zurückfallen können und
diese debatte braucht es aus meiner
sicht in den nächsten wochen mit der
mertz sickerte durch sparen will die
sogenannte funkzellen ordnung nutzen um
infizierte und ihre kontaktpersonen zu
lokalisieren
ein schwerer grundrechtseingriff den der
koalitionspartner spd in letzter sekunde
stoppte auch das innenministerium will
mobilfunk daten auswerten infizierte
worten in einem internen papier heißt es
um das testen schneller und effizienter
zu machen ist längerfristig der einsatz
von big data und location tracking
unumgänglich durch die sorge vor der
krankheit herrscht gerade ein klima in
dem jede grundrechts einschränkungen
willkommen ist natürlich unsere aufgabe
nun darauf zu achten dass wir dieser
dieser gesundheitlichen krise nicht noch
eine grundrechts krise hinterher werfen
haben ja sowieso schon noch eine
wirtschaftskrise inzwischen haben wir
eigentlich genug riesen jens spahn setzt
nun auf eine handy-app die kontakte
zwischen infizierten und nicht
infizierten erfasst alexander stinker
und thomas kölsch haben genauso eine app
entwickelt
geht ein corona infizierter zum arzt
kann dieser anonym eine warnung
verschicken und zwar an all die die
ebenfalls eine solche bluetooth app
installiert haben
es werden nur die gewarnt die in einem
entsprechenden abstand waren die über
eine bestimmte zeit mit mir zusammen
waren und die zur infektiösen in der
effektiven phase r krankheit mit mit
einem patienten oder mit einem nicht
erkrankten zusammen waren nur dann sagt
der algorithmus macht es sinn zu warnen
wissenschaftler aus ganz europa darunter
vom frauenhofer und vom
robert-koch-institut haben sich in
diesen tagen zusammen geschlossen um
einen gemeinsamen standard für eine
solche app zu entwickeln
denn es braucht ein system das alle
benutzen
klar ist es soll freiwillig sein und
anonym
wir können natürlich nur hoffen dass
hier am ende die privatsphäre nicht auf
der strecke bleibt denn das sind immer
nur winzige kleine daten die mit erfasst
werden oder nicht mit erfasst werden die
hier aus so einer app einen absoluten
albtraum machen können das sind wenige
zeilen programmiercode in singapur ist
eine ähnliche app schon im einsatz
die dabei verwendete bluetooth technik
erkennt einen datenaustausch zwischen
mobiltelefonen über kurze entfernung
doch wenn bluetooth permanent
eingeschaltet ist ist die sicherheit des
handys gefährdet wenn zb die bluetooth
schnittstelle auf dem smartphone
geöffnet werden soll um nähe oder nahe
kontakte festzustellen
zu möglicherweise infizierten personen
dann hat das natürlich auch eine
auswirkung auf die it-sicherheit und
eine solche offene schnittstelle könnte
dann auch für andere zwecke missbraucht
werden das virus weltweit
begehrlichkeiten nach noch mehr
überwachung
besonders weit vorn israel sie waren in
der nähe eines corona infizierten gehen
sie in quarantäne
diese nachricht bekamen viele israelis
in den letzten tagen auf ihre
mobiltelefone die regierung ordnet mit
hilfe des inlandsgeheimdienstes corona
infizierte und kontaktpersonen eine
spezialeinheit der polizei geht mit den
daten auf die jagd wenn jemand positiv
getestet wird wird er verfolgt um
sicherzugehen dass er auch zu hause
bleibt
wenn er da nicht ist fahren wir raus und
suchen in der nachbarschaft so wie jetzt
gerade
wir wollen dass die leute in den
vierteln und städten zu sicher wie
möglich sind man muss aber nur zu
unseren nachbarn nach polen schauen um
zu sehen wie schnell aus big data big
brother wird das digitale ministerium
überwacht mit spontan abfragen ob die
quarantäne eingehalten wird
viele deutsche wären bereit eine app zu
installieren wenn sie dafür andere
freiheiten zurückgewinnen
aber nur freiwillig sagt michael kroner
aus jena kiosk besitzer martin michel
geht schon die neue mundschutz pflicht
in seiner stadt zu weit
also ich habe den mund schon vorher auch
vor der pflicht ich finde es allgemein
gut wenn in engen räumen leute
mundschutz tragen ich glaube aber dass
man nicht alles verpflichtend machen
solltet die verhältnismäßigkeit musste
immer wieder geklärt werden und
übertriebene angst hat gut getan
momentan kann man ja nichts dagegen die
maßnahmen protestieren die man für
unverhältnismäßig immerhin michael
gruner darf sich wieder auf seine
geliebte bank setzen mit ausreichend
abstand
die stadt hat das verbot aufgehoben das
virus so scheint es ist auch für
grundrechte gefährlich
[Musik]